QUITE A HIT.
DR. ?
>> Tucker: REMARKABLE.
BENJAMIN HALL FOR US, THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THIS CAN HAPPEN TO HIM, A LOT OF
US SHOULD BE WORRIED AND WE ARE
WORRIED, WORRIED ENOUGH TO
ENDURE THINGS THAT JUST A MONTH
AGO WOULD SEEM PREPOSTEROUS.
LAST WEEK, LEADER OF THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION ANNOUNCED
THAT IN RESPONSE TO THE SPREAD
OF THIS VIRUS, AUTHORITIES MAY
HAVE TO ENTER PEOPLE’S HOMES AND
REMOVE FAMILY MEMBERS PRESUMABLY
BY FORCE.
>> IN MOST PARTS OF THE WORLD,
MOST OF THE TRANSITION IT’S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN MANY
COUNTRIES NOW IS HAPPENING IN
THE HOUSEHOLD THAT FAMILY LEVEL.
IN SOME SENSE, TRANSMISSION HAS
BEEN TAKEN OFF THE STREETS AND
PUSHED BACK INTO FAMILY UNITS.
NOW, WE NEED TO GO AND LOOK AT
FAMILIES TO FIND THOSE PEOPLE
WHO MAY BE SICK AND REMOVE THEM
AND ISOLATE THEM IN A SAFE AND
DIGNIFIED MANNER.
>> JUST SO YOU KNOW, WE ARE
COMING TO YOUR HOUSE, SEIZING
YOUR CHILDREN, AND "ISOLATING
THEM IN A SAFE AND DIGNIFIED
MANNER," WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
THAT’S NOT SOMETHING UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES OFFICIALS
CASUALLY DROPPED DURING
BRIEFINGS.
IT’S THE KIND OF STATEMENT THAT
MIGHT TRIGGER VIOLENCE.
PEOPLE DON’T RESPOND WELL, HE
SAID IT LIKE IT WAS NO BIG DEAL
AND THAT’S HOW THE MEDIA TREATED
IT.
DIDN’T MAKE HEADLINES IN ANY OF
THE MAJOR NEWSPAPERS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT’S THE KIND OF MOMENT WE ARE
IN.
SO HOW LONG WILL THIS MOMENT
LAST?
ON FRIDAY, THE MAYOR OF
LOS ANGELES PREDICTED THAT THE
FIRST IN A SERIES OF LOCKDOWNS
WILL GO ON UNTIL JUNE.
>> ONE OF THE THING THAT
CONCERNS ME, NOT ONE OF THOSE
IMMEDIATE CONCERNS, BUT THIS
DRAWS OUT THROUGH THE SUMMER AND
THEN THE COLD WEATHER COMES
AROUND AND THEN THERE’S ANOTHER
WAVE, HOW DO YOU AS A LEADER
THINK ABOUT THIS?
>> EARLY ON, THEY SAID IT WOULD
BE A COUPLE OF DAYS OR A FEW
WEEKS AND I SAID IT’S AT LEAST
TWO MONTHS AND IF WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN THIS, WE CAN
EXPECT A SECOND SPIKE IN THE
LATE FALL OR EARLY WINTER.
THAT’S HOW VIRUSES WORK.
WE BETTER STEAL OURSELVES FOR A
SECOND AND EVEN THIRD ROUND OF
THIS.
WE ALSO NEED TO BE NIMBLE ENOUGH
TO KNOW WE ARE NOT GOING TO FLIP
A SWITCH ONE DAY AT HER AND THE
BACK ON.
>> Tucker: A SECOND AND EVEN
THIRD ROUND OF LOCKDOWNS, THAT’S
A LONG TIME.
PREDICTS THE DISRUPTION MAY BE
EVEN MORE SEVERE THAN THAT, "WE
SHOULD CERTAINLY BE PREPARED FOR
A MEANINGFUL LEVEL OF DELIBERATE
SUSPENSION OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
FOR THE REST OF THE YEAR.
WHILE IT WOULD BE NICE TO HAVE A
GOOD REASON FOR THIS AND
EVERYONE WANTS THEIR SINCERELY,
THE ARGUMENTS WERE STARTING TO
SOUND STRANGE.
IN A MUCH DISCUSSED ARTICLE,
THEY SAID LIFTING THE LOCKDOWN
AT ALL EVEN MANY MONTHS FROM NOW
WOULD BE NEGLIGENT, "AS LONG AS
A LARGE MAJORITY OF THE
POPULATION REMAINS UNINFECTED,
LIFTING CONTAINMENT MEASURES
WILL LEAD TO AN EPIDEMIC ALMOST
AS LARGE AS WHAT HAPPEN WITHOUT
HAVING MEDICATIONS IN PLACE AT
ALL."
THAT SOUNDS PLAUSIBLE WHEN YOU
READ IT AND IN FACT IT SOUNDS
LIKE SCIENCE, BUT IS IT SCIENCE?
A LARGE MAJORITY OF THE
POPULATION REMAINS UNINFECTED,
THEY SAY.
BUT IS THAT TRUE?
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT’S TRUE.
NOBODY CAN SAY WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THE AMERICAN POPULATION IS
INFECTED OR HAS BEEN INFECTED.
THERE HAVE BEEN LARGE-SCALE
RANDOMIZED TESTS HERE, WE DON’T
KNOW WHEN THE DISEASE FIRST
ARRIVED IN THE UNITED STATES.
THERE’S INFORMED SPECULATION
THAT THIS HAS BEEN HERE SINCE
LATE NOVEMBER OR DECEMBER.
THE FIRST CONFIRMED CASE TO
JANUARY 15 IN WASHINGTON STATE.
AN UNNAMED 35-YEAR-OLD CHINESE
IMMIGRANT LANDED IN THE
UNITED STATES AFTER VISITING HIS
FAMILY IN WUHAN AND LANDED IN A
HOSPITAL OUTSIDE OF SEATTLE.
DEPENDING ON HOW YOU COUNT, THE
VIRUS HAS BEEN CIRCULATING AMONG
US FOR UP TO FOUR MONTHS NOW.
FOR MOST OF THAT TIME, NO
SYSTEMATIC ATTEMPT TO QUARANTINE
THE POPULATION.
HOW MANY AMERICANS WERE INFECTED
OVER THAT.
MATT WE DON’T EVEN HAVE A
BALLPARK NUMBER FOR THAT BUT IT
COULD BE ENORMOUS BECAUSE IT
TURNS OUT MUCH EASIER TO
TRANSMIT THAT WE THOUGHT IT WAS.
ON FRIDAY, YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED
THE CDC ISSUED NEW GUIDANCE ON
MASK USE.
THEY NOW RECOMMEND WEARING A
CLOTH FACE COVERINGS IN PUBLIC.
WHY DID THEY MAKE THAT CHANGE?
RESEARCHERS ARE LEARNING MORE
ABOUT HOW THIS VIRUS MOVES FROM
PERSON TO PERSON.
THEY NOW BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE CO
TRANSMITTED BY SPEAKING.
THAT RECOMMENDATION WAS BASED ON
THE BELIEVE THE VIRUS LIVED
MOSTLY ON SERVICES AND THAT’S
NOT THE CASE.
WE ARE STILL NOT EXACTLY SURE
AND THIS IS INTERESTING TO KNOW,
IT APPEARS TO BE ASTONISHINGLY
WIDESPREAD.
AN ARTICLE IN THE ITALIAN MADE
OUT LAST THURSDAY DESCRIBED A
BLOOD DRIVE IN A VILLAGE IN THE
MOST INFECTED PART OF THE
COUNTRY OF THE 60 PEOPLE WHO
SHOWED UP TO GIVE BLOOD, 40
TESTED POSITIVE FOR CORONAVIRUS.
NO ONE HAD SHOWN SYMPTOMS OF IT
OR KNOW THAT THEY HAD IT.
KEEP IN MIND THEY HAVE BEEN
STRICTLY LOCKED DOWN BY
GOVERNMENT ORDER SINCE MARCH 9TH
ALMOST A MONTH AGO.
ABOUT 70% OF THIS GROUP GOT
ANYWAY.
A REPORT FROM HONG KONG IN
FEBRUARY SUGGESTED THAT A WOMAN
DIAGNOSED WITH CORONAVIRUS MAY
HAVE INFECTED OTHERS TEN FLOORS
AWAY IN THE SAME APARTMENT
BUILDING EVEN THOUGH SHE NEVER
CAME INTO CONTACT WITH ANY OF
THEM.
HEALTH OFFICIALS CONCLUDED THE
VIRUS LIKELY TRAVELED THROUGH
PLUMBING PIPES TO DIFFERENT
APARTMENTS AND IT WASN’T A WILD
GUESS.
IN 2003, AN OUTBREAK OF SARS
SPREAD THE SAME WAY.
SO IT STARTING TO LOOK LIKE THE
CORONAVIRUS IS MORE
TRANSMISSIBLE THAN WE EXPECTED
OR WERE TOLD.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, IT ALSO SEEMS
FAR LESS LETHAL OVERALL.
PEOPLE ARE STILL DYING IN LARGE
NUMBERS, NOT ALL OF THEM ARE
SICK OR OLD AND THAT’S
TERRIFYING TO WATCH.
BUT THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT MANY
INFECTED PEOPLE ARE NOT SICK.
ICELAND HAS TESTED A LARGER
PERCENTAGE OF ITS POPULATION
THAN ANY COUNTRY IN THE WORLD,
TESTING ABOUT 5% OF ALL
CITIZENS.
UNITED STATES BY COMPARISON HAS
.3%.
HALF OF THOSE WHO TESTED
POSITIVE AND ICELAND HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY ASYMPTOMATIC.
SO GIVEN ALL OF THIS, WHAT IS A
WISE RESPONSE TO THIS PANDEMIC?
HISTORICALLY, HEALTH OFFICIALS
HAVE USED QUARANTINE TO CONTAIN
INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
UNTIL NOW, A QUARANTINE
CONSISTED OF DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO PROTECT THE
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE.
IN THIS CASE, THAT WOULD INCLUDE
THE ELDERLY AND
IMMUNOSUPPRESSED.
WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA THAT
TARGETED QUARANTINES WORK RIGHT
IF THEY’VE BEEN USED FOR
CENTURIES AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT WE DID.
INSTEAD, THE UNITED STATES AND
MANY OTHER COUNTRIES INSTITUTED
MASS QUARANTINES IN WHICH
GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN ENTIRELY
NATIONS FOR LONG PERIODS, THIS
NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
MASS QUARANTINES MAKES SENSE IF
YOU ARE FAIRLY CERTAIN IT WILL
IT PREVENT MASS INFECTIONS, BUT
ARE WE CERTAIN OF THAT?
DESPITE WHAT YOU MIGHT HEAR ON
TELEVISION, WE ARE NOT CERTAIN
OF THAT STILL.
THERE ARE SOME INDICATIONS IT
HASN’T BEEN AS EFFECTIVE AS WE
HOPED IT WOULD BE.
ITALY IMPOSED ONE OF THE
TOUGHEST LOCKDOWNS IN EUROPE AND
ALMOST A MONTH LATER AN
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF AT
LEAST ONE TOWN HAS BEEN INFECTED
WITH THE VIRUS ANYWAY.
IT’S POSSIBLE TO IMAGINE THAT
I’M MASS QUARANTINES MIGHT STOP
TRANSMISSION OF A VIRUS AND
MIGHT WORK IF IT ACTUALLY
SEPARATED PEOPLE.
CITIZENS WERE FORCED TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES AND NOT HAVE ANY
INTERACTION WITH OTHER PEOPLE
BUT WE ARE NOT DOING THAT IN THE
UNITED STATES AND WE NEVER WILL
DO THAT HERE.
TOO MANY AMERICANS WITH LOANS,
PEOPLE WOULD STARVE TO DEATH.
INSTEAD, THE DIRECTION WE ARE
LIVING UNDER HIS STAY HOME
EXCEPT TO BUY FOOD.
THE ONE PLACE YOU CAN GO IS THE
SUPERMARKET WHERE EVERYONE ELSE
IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD HAS BEEN
THIS WEEK.
FROM AN EPIDEMIOLOGICAL
STANDPOINT, THIS IS LUNACY.
YOU WANTED TO INFECT AN ENTIRE
POPULATION, YOU’D ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE IN A SPECIFIC ZIP CODE
TO MEET REGULARLY AND WON A
CLOSE LOCATION.
DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
AUTHORITIES MUST KNOW IT DOESN’T
MAKE SENSE, BUT INSTEAD OF
CHANGING COURSE OR FINE-TUNING,
THEY ARE DOUBLING DOWN HOPING
THAT VEHEMENCE WILL COMPENSATE
FOR BAD SCIENCE.
HERE IS THE MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES
JUST LAST WEEK.
>> IF YOU’VE OBSERVED RECURRING
VIOLATIONS, PLEASE CONTINUE TO
LET US KNOW.
THE OLD EXPRESSION ABOUT
SNITCHES, IN THIS CASE, SNITCHES
GET REWARDS.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR TURNING
FOLKS IN AND MAKING SURE WE ARE
ALL SAFE.
>> Tucker: SO YOU JUST SAW THE
MAYOR OF OUR SECOND-BIGGEST CITY
OFFERING TO PAY CITIZENS TO
SNITCH ON THEIR NEIGHBORS FOR
AMONG OTHER THINGS DARING TO GO
TO WORK.
WORKING AS ONE ACTIVITY WE’VE
DECIDED SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED.
JOGGING, FISHING, BEING
EMPLOYED, A MASSIVE THREAT TO
PUBLIC HEALTH.
WE’VE DECIDED THAT OFFICES ARE
SOMEHOW MORE DANGEROUS THAN
SUPERMARKETS, FAR MORE DANGEROUS
BUT NO ONE HAS BOTHERED TO
EXPLAIN HOW.
THE RESULT OF THIS, BY SOME
ESTIMATES MORE THAN 17 MILLION
AMERICANS ARE UNEMPLOYED RIGHT
NOW, THE HIGHEST NUMBER IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
A YEAR FROM NOW, AND WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT THIS, HOW WILL ALL
OF US FEEL ABOUT DECISIONS WE
MADE IN THE FACE OF THIS
PANDEMIC?
IS THERE A SINGLE PERSON WHO
SINCERELY EXPECTS THE
CORONAVIRUS ITSELF WILL HURT
MORE PEOPLE IN THE END AND THE
DAMAGE WE ARE CAUSING IN
RESPONSE TO IT.
PROBABLY NOT.
MASS UNEMPLOYMENT IS ALMOST
CERTAIN TO CAUSE FAR MORE HARM
INCLUDING PHYSICAL HARM TO THE
AVERAGE FAMILIES.
IN 1967, TWO PSYCHIATRIC
RESEARCHERS DECIDED TO RANK
TRAUMATIC LIFE EVENTS AND HOW
PROFOUNDLY THE AFFECTED PEOPLE’S
HEALTH.
STRESS CAN KILL YOU AND WE KNOW
THAT AND THEY WANTED TO
DETERMINE WHICH KINDS OF STRESS
FOR THE MOST DANGEROUS.
THE DOCTORS FOUND THAT LOSING A
JOB RANK HIGH ON THE LIST OF
HEALTH DEGRADING TRAUMAS.
JOBLESSNESS CAME IN WELL ABOVE
DEATH OF A CLOSE FRIEND TO PUT
IT IN SOME PERSPECTIVE.
YOU’VE EVER FOUND YOURSELF
UNEMPLOYED WITH DEFENDANTS TO
TAKE CARE OF, YOU UNDERSTAND
THIS.
UNFORTUNATELY, MANY OF OUR
POLICYMAKERS DON’T UNDERSTAND.
THEY DON’T HAVE MUCH INTEREST IN
MIDDLE-CLASS JOB LOSS OR ITS
CONSEQUENCES.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE THEY’VE
IGNORED IT FOR DECADES, NOT TO
MENTION THE FAMILY
DISINTEGRATION AND THE DRUG
EPIDEMIC THAT HAS FUN.
SO FAR, 10,000 AMERICANS HAVE
DIED FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
THAT IS A TRAGEDY.
BUT IS NOT THE ONLY TRAGEDY AND
PROGRESS IN THIS COUNTRY.
IN 2018, MORE THAN 67,000
AMERICANS DIED OF DRUG
OVERDOSES.
THE YEAR BEFORE, MORE THAN
70,000 DIED.
THAT’S MORE THAN THE ENTIRE
POPULATION OF THE TOWNS MOST OF
US GREW UP IN.
AND THOSE TOTALS ARE FAR LOWER
THAN THE REAL NUMBER ACCORDING
TO PEOPLE WHO STUDY.
THE DRUG EPIDEMIC HAS
PERMANENTLY CHANGE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS BUT FOR SOME
REASON, THEY HAVE NOT KEPT A
RUNNING TALLY OF DRUG
CASUALTIES.
WHY IS THAT?
YOU KNOW WHY.
IS NOT THEIR PEER GROUP.
DOESN’T SEEM REAL.
THEY ARE NOT THAT INTERESTED.
THE SAME THING IS GOING ON NOW.
THE SHUTDOWN WAS CRUSHING
COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS OR
NONPROFIT EXECUTIVES FOR GREEN
ENERGY LOBBYIST, IT WOULD HAVE
ENDED LAST WEEK.
INSTEAD, IT’S MAINLY SERVICE
WORKERS AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO HAVE BEEN HURT AND
THEY ARE NOT ON TELEVISION
TALKING ABOUT WHAT THEY’RE GOING
THROUGH.
YOU NEED TO LOOK CLOSELY TO SEE
THE SUFFERING.
AT THE HEAD OF INDIANA’S FAMILY
AND SOCIAL SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED A CALL
TO THE STATES MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUICIDE PREVENTION HOTLINE HAD
GONE FROM ABOUT 1,000 TO 25,000
A DAY.
CALLS TO INDIANA’S ADDICTION
HOTLINES HAVE RISEN DRAMATICALLY
AS WELL.
REPORTS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HAS
SPIKED IN THIS COUNTRY AND
AROUND THE WORLD.
IN FRANCE, THEY ROSE 32% IN A
SINGLE WEEK.
SOMEDAY, WE LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
ON THE CHILD ABUSE GOING ON
DURING THIS LOCKED DOWN AND WE
WILL ALL FEEL SICK TO OUR
STOMACHS.
ONCE AGAIN, CORONAVIRUS IS NOT
THE ONLY BAD THING THAT IS
HAPPENING IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW,
HORRIFYING AS IT IS.
WE SHOULD NEVER MINIMIZE THE
DANGER OF THIS PANDEMIC OR
MINIMIZE OUR OBLIGATION TO
RESPOND TO IT WISELY.
A THOUGHTFUL PERSON WANTS TO
REOPEN BASEBALL STADIUMS FOR
BOOK A CRUISE TO SHANGHAI BUT
THERE HAS TO BE A MORE BALANCED
COURSE AND THE ONE WE ARE ON
NOW.
FOR MOST PEOPLE GOING TO WORK
CANNOT BE MORE DANGEROUS THAN
BUYING PRODUCE AT SAFEWAY TWICE
A WEEK AND IF IT IS, TELL US HOW
IT IS MORE DANGEROUS AND BE
SPECIFIC WHEN YOU DESCRIBE THAT.
OTHERWISE IT’S TIME TO START